Santa's secrets hey is that sad to hear
you hear Santa where's Santa let's see
if we can find him he's somewhere here
oh wait a minute there isn't there yeah
hey Conan how's it going
now as Santa do you have any secrets
you'd like to share
oh sure I got secrets lots of Secrets
but you wouldn't want to hear them come
on Santa we'd love to hear one of your
secrets wouldn't we okay just one just
one it's kind of embarrassing though
when I'm in your home on Christmas Eve I
lick all the doorknobs it's a compulsion
oh and when I fly from my slave from
Mexico I usually smuggle in five or six
illegals charge them - all right that's
Santa that's a little bit creepy but
there you have it anyways Santa's
secrets so it's good to know that
there's a Conan you want to hear another
secret yeah sure okay all right good the
whip I use in my reindeer is the same
one mrs. Claus uses on me the rest of
the year I see you when you're sleeping
and I know when you're awake
thanks to hittin webcams yeah I see you
do all sorts of stuff all sorts of stuff
oh yeah you've been naughty Andy but
Santa thinks it's nice
Sanna parent well anyway let's move also
also elves have the same life expectancy
of goldfish yeah
the North Pole is 90% elf graves does
elf graves as far as the eye can see
that's just depressing like that thank
you so and here's a secret you spend as
much time as I do looking at the back
end of a reindeer and you start to like
it let's wrap it out oh also I have a
knife in my beard
so let that be a lesson to you children
don't quit start
[Applause]
you